the world's worst covet 19 outbreak
continues to spiral out of control in
india
for the fifth straight day on monday the
country recorded more than 300 000 cases
the highest global surges ever recorded
the increasing caseload has far
outstripped available medical supplies
particularly
of oxygen the us uk germany singapore
and the european union among others have
stepped forward
with help help that's badly needed to
relieve the pressure
on india's overstretched health care
system here's more from dw correspondent
nimisha
as well there is an expectation that a
lot of these
supplies these ventilators these oxygen
concentrators
should be reaching india soon we have
already gotten supplies from singapore
there are also offers from the uae saudi
arabia
and other other people in the other
countries in the
in the neighborhood as well even china
and pakistan have reached out with
offers to support of course the eu and
the us have also spoken out now
germany has said that it will ensure
that any supply bottlenecks for vaccine
manufacturing
are addressed because this of course
also influences
global reception of the vaccine the us
has been criticized for
blocking the supply of crucial vaccine
raw material over the past few weeks
but now both president joe biden and
vice president kamila harris
have said that they would support india
in a time of crisis much like
india supported the us when its
resources were stretched
during the pandemic and in the midst of
the crisis in the country social media
platforms like facebook and twitter
have emerged as life savers literally
indians are sharing pleas for help
and information on availability of beds
oxygen and other medical supplies
but it's also prompted criticism of the
government's response to the crisis
criticism that the government has
decided to go after
last week following a legal request from
the government
twitter blocked over 50 tweets in india
that were mostly critical of the
government according to a media report
the government felt
these posts constituted social media
misuse
and for more on this i'm joined now by
pratik sinha he's the co-founder of alt
news
a fact checking portal in india pratik
joins me now
from ahmedabad in western india prateek
you're focused on a daily basis
on reading out fake news and
misinformation online
in india did most of the tweets that
have been blocked
meet that standard not at all there was
no misinformation
these are people expressing their
opinions about the ground situation for
example
one act of anith kumar singh saying that
it is difficult to get medication
another
uh you know member of parliament from
another political party saying that you
know the prime minister should be held
responsible
uh a journalist a senior journalist from
an organization called abp news
saying that you know you criticized the
chamath incident you know which happened
where the muslim community was
criticized for holding a religious
congregation but you're not doing the
same for
hindus who are who held a similar
religious congregation in something
called kummela
so these were all very genuine criticism
with no element of misinformation or
hate and
does not at all meet the standards of
twitter as a platform to police these
tweets
so is the government then using its
powers
to block dissent on social media
absolutely all of these are tweets which
would be considered critical of the
government
and the government is uh forcing
platforms and unfortunately the
platforms are buckling as well
but the government is forcing platforms
to adhere to certain lines where
you know where descent is curved
now you mentioned the platforms are
buckling to the government's
instructions why
because in india if you have to do
business you have to be
friends with the government if we keep
talking about ease of business but
it is ease of business for friends and
we have seen this in other platforms
also
even on facebook there are individuals
working in very high positions who
at one point of time used to do
propaganda for bjp so
uh this is not a case of just one
platform all platforms
in india social media platforms want to
do business india is a huge market for
them
and for them to be successful they have
to be friends with the government
what exactly are the legal powers that
the government of india has
that allow it to ask social media
platforms to remove
content deemed objectionable
so everything is not in a legal realm
right
there can be various things we have seen
in india that
um you know for example opposition
political parties or
media organizations recently they are
subjected to
uh income tax rates raised by the
enforcement directorate and things like
that so
uh government can uh pressurize business
houses in multiple ways you know
whether it's permission for a new
building new land
there are multiple ways in which a
government can block the progress
of a business it is not only in legal
realms or you know through
though they have also used those kind of
threats that is
you know if you don't take down these
set of tweets in the past when there was
another
problematic hashtag that was trended
government you did use
legal threats as well but that is not
the government has more means than that
to
intimidate business houses but overall
our social media platforms
helping in the current crisis i mean the
number of tweets that we have seen for
example you have citizens
coordinating and organizing amongst
themselves
trying to find responses to this
nationwide crisis
is that a major positive to come out of
this
it is but these are two distinct issues
uh definitely
uh twitter especially has been a huge
platform
uh for you know this kind of
crowdsourcing resources and all news as
a not-for-profit organization
every month we do crowdfunding and
twitter is one of our biggest platform
to be able to do that and that is the
nature of the platform and
we are appreciated appreciative of that
but but that
that is a very distinct matter from uh
the policing
or from their inability to take down
hate speech
there are multiple times when we have
written to twitter about accounts which
have been suspended which come back and
continue to put out hate speech and
which is not which is against the
policies and they don't act at all
so these are two distinct possibilities
uh distinct issues that
you know a platform being useful and how
a platform
is buckling under government pressure
speaking of buckling under
government pressure do you see in the
midst of the present coronavirus crisis
is there actually an increase in
misleading information and deliberate
fake news that is being spread
absolutely
there's a huge increase in both medical
misinformation
as well as political misinformation the
last one year has been just
in you know endless amounts of uh
political and
medical misinformation political
misinformation is very closely linked in
india to current affairs
and it is organized that is it is used
to set narratives so
and a lot of it comes from the
right-wing government so if things are
going wrong
then false narratives are created using
social media
so with and it is done in a very
organized manner and we have seen a huge
uptick of it pratik sanako founder of
old news thank you so much